its e3 2016 rob you and i just watched
title to single player oh my goodness
that was so impressed yeah but you think
it was exactly what i think everyone
wanted was finally a single player
campaign I think you're right and I
think the first game suffered from not
having a single player campaign I think
like if you're gonna play a multiplayer
game is it's good to have some sort of
narrative some context what you're
actually playing so I think it's really
cool the games introducing a single
image yeah um so let's just get right
into a trailer meet a little bit of a
breakdown you know it starts off with
earth well I'm a job it destroyed earth
yo you know really vamping on the idea
that you know it's it's humanization of
different planets colonization excuse me
moving out I guess the vo was kind of
hinting at a dynamic with you know for
the pilot in yeah don't even think the
story is going to star the Titan I think
he's gonna be the star of the show and
it's got a new pilot Jack Cooper and he
has three protocols right the first one
is to link to the pilot second one is to
uphold the mission third one is to
protect the pilot in the even like
kicked it off saying your last pilot was
ki that's right you get you know even
though they do know what happened in
that yeah precisely doesn't tell you why
he's linked to the new pilot Jack Cooper
there's like a level of mystery to that
so yeah there's some story to it now and
it's quite cool that we're actually
talking to Titans as well right we can
understand them a bit Bella sure uh yeah
moving through it they kind of hint
that you know there's that one scene
where you're sliding off the roof and
the Titan catches that was awesome it
was really ask that was awesome and I
think that speaks to I think in entitled
to this can be way more nimble tysons I
think they were showing that throughout
the trailer right these were these
Titans were doing kung fu there was a
come through Titans regular you dislike
a kick and then like at the gun oh yeah
that was fantastic totally I'm do you
think there's like some speculation that
tightens can start doing there a new
jumps and stuff there was a little bit
of that what those are things that
they're gonna be doing that you reckon
that's gonna happen possibly I don't
know yeah I mean I don't see why not I
feel like that's the planes like the
next phase right is seeing more of these
Titans and actions they're they're
special so to speak and then of course
i'd say the the ultimate shot that we
all at the end of day we all needed and
we didn't even know it was what goes on
inside the ship that drops the titans
right yeah talking to the robot 6 the
latest the troxy though dude oh that was
insane yahoo okay when I saw the I got
chills so it's like I can't wait to do
that um anything else from the trailer
um yeah there was like iguanas right
these like these large winged iguanas
yeah right am I am i imagining that sure
I saw that there was that and then just
prior look like I got a vibe from avatar
of old movies there's that one there's a
one kind of doglike creature from avatar
that like kind of had like the what's
the typical source from like Jurassic
Park a head like yeah yeah yeahs thing i
miss apiece from that of course after i
had like you know next and everything
that I'm so the prince that we're gonna
see a bit more of the world too low
right these are just the Rhenus anymore
that we're gonna bash around them yeah
these are like sort of worlds are we
gonna see a bit more of so it's an
interesting direction for the series oh
absolutely yet but then of course the
last shot that I want to touch on was uh
after way says but essentially the Titan
grabs you and then throws you onto like
a park or area yeah which to me says
is here is a here is a campaign
structure where you're maybe just like
kind of leap frog and around your house
of the titans you know very yeah like
back and forth nature to like traversal
when everything like that completely
yeah I'm quite by throat you mean like
he tossed him like oh about half a mile
away oh yeah like an insane distant
right and I believe you said trust me
trust you I'm worried when he toss them
he said trust me which I thought was
really cool so again we're super excited
I think most people are who are fans of
titanfall it was exactly what everyone
wanted the only gripe my head with first
game was hey yeah a single player
campaign and we got it awesome cool well
thanks for Rob thank you